all right we're still at the national
conservatism conference i'm still dave
rubin and i'm with a man who needs no
introduction that's what people keep
saying about me all conference long
which i don't know i don't know what
that means is it that like they don't
really know what to say about you they
don't like you man i've never googled
dave rubin welcome i'm with uh friend
and colleague michael knowles first off
knowles you lost a little weight thank
you yes thank you i had how did you do
it i had put on the nashville 20.
and then as one does you know with the
biscuits and the gravy and the chicken
yeah and the fried bologna which i did
not even know was a thing until it was
baloney no i mean it was a lot and so i
was very quickly becoming like a big fat
suburban guy and so i said okay you know
i'm gonna put some limits on it and
actually this relates to the topic
that i'm speaking about here and that a
lot of people are speaking about at the
national conservatism conference
limits you know you got you need some
limits even those of us who like the
fried bologna who are kind of done i'm
married what do i don't care it's not
like i'm going to the club but still
just to be in good virtuous shape you
got to keep things a little a little
tight i mean somewhat joking aside but
not fully joking aside i have noticed
since i've been in more of these crazy
right wing radical conservative circles
that i now travel in people do look
better they seem better they seem
happier but i but i don't mean it looks
like as if looks are so important but i
mean it has something to do with
responsibility yes the they're we're not
saying that you know well it might be
the case the conservatives just are
they're just born better looking it's
possible but but putting that aside for
a second yeah there are these really sad
videos you can see them on youtube or
tick tock or whatever
of like a pretty girl who's like a
pretty normal girl and raised in a
normal kind of household and then she
tries leftism and she just takes a few
puffs of leftism at first but then she's
mainlining leftism and what happens she
gets the crazy haircut and all the
tattoos and the face tats and the crazy
clothing and it's and it it doesn't look
good because you
one thing that conservatives are good at
and it kind of hampers this politically
but it's probably good for our personal
lives yeah is we're actually good at
moderation usually right we're good at
not going too far in one direction or
the other we kind of like things the way
they are we want to keep things they're
not the most excitable we're not the
most excitable people and so it means
that the left is a lot better at
aggression than you know actual
political tactics but for us it means we
look better
do you think and i actually think we're
going to hold this for probably a day or
so so i'm really going to get you on the
hook right now
do you think that virginia is going to
go well and thus
save the republic so i try not to make
uh predictions on these things because
that's why i'm asking you and then
holding it
yeah but i'll say right now speaking on
tuesday afternoon yeah
if i had to put odds i'd say 60 40
mcauliffe oh really i would and really
look i think the yunkan campaign is
is the greatest republican campaign i've
seen in virginia in my lifetime i think
that this issue that they focused on the
education the anti-crt is the greatest
grassroots movement since the tea party
i think it's more grassroots actually
than the tea party i've been calling it
the crt party it's parents who
that's pretty good
yeah
even more than don't tax me as much even
more than stop spending all this money
don't
teach my kid radical racial and sexual
ideologies that is something that really
resonates with a whole lot of people
across a whole lot of demographics and
so
all of that is
the caveat i think if any republican is
going to win in virginia it's going to
be glenn younkin right now however the
democrats have a massive registration
advantage and
they're they're they've rigged the
system i mean i don't i want us to get
kicked off youtube or whatever i'm on
locals in rumble now you are free to say
whatever you want they rigged the system
in the sense that they have changed the
election integrity laws throughout the
country to be more advantageous to them
when it's just election day republicans
do better when it's election month or
two months and widespread mail-ins and
voter harvesting and all these sorts of
things democrats do better and so
they've used covet as the excuse to
change all of those rules and uh and
they don't get more corrupt than
mcauliffe i mean he is a clinton machine
politician so i wouldn't be surprised if
he holds on but i will say this if
if junkin won i'm now speaking you know
from the future on wednesday really i'm
really taxing you're back to this it is
very tricky but if if yunkan manages to
pull it off i think it will do a great
deal to restore confidence in the entire
regime in the entire election system
because right now a lot of republicans
think
we can't win the regime is exercising
all of its power we are permanently
disadvantaged we shouldn't even go vote
and if if junkin can pull it off i think
it's going to give republicans a big
help in 22 and 24. can i give you the
reverse of that which is that if he does
not win oh sorry if he if he does win
that the democrats then will say the
system is now all rigged which they're
saying anyway despite wins yes they're
still saying because they're they just
have it there right so like stacey
abrams is always out there saying the
election was stolen from her terry
mcauliffe said it in the year of our
lord 2021 he said stacey abrams won the
election is that is that an untenable
thing for a democracy that we we really
are going to end up in a situation and
and partly for good reason i mean look
you fled california a lot after you told
me you were going to stay but that's
we've already
we've already been through that i said
uh right after i gave you a final kiss
yeah i said good night dave i'll see you
in the morning kiss on the cheek and i
betrayed you yeah it was really it was
quite i know you do come from a line of
people in sicily that have a way of you
know um
but but in california i mean i've used
this example a million times during the
recall election the envelope that you
got no matter which way you folded your
ballot you could either see that you
voted yes on recall call or larry
elder's name no matter which way you
folded it right and all you had to do
was hold the envelope up to basic light
like this like that's a problem yeah no
it's a coincidence it's totally i know i
know coincidences no and so this is a
problem for the system of government
that
neither party
will accept the results of the elections
and don't forget democrats started it
right democrats in terry mcauliffe
running for virginia right now
still refuses to acknowledge that george
w bush won the 2000 election right he
was asking and he was not he was not the
only one and he was not the only one and
people have been doing this hillary
still has not really conceded the 2016
election stacey abrams obviously is
still the the governor the pretend
governor of
georgia yeah and uh but but it's not
just the same by the way it's not just
that republicans lose and they don't
believe it and democrats lose losing
they don't believe it
the democrats have all the power they
have all the power they control the
government the media the schools the
tech the what corporations which is to
say all the corporations they control
everything okay and so
for republicans to look at that and say
hey you guys are
like changing the election rules and
you're suppressing stories about hunter
biden
on twitter or whatever you know
i think we have a legitimate claim for
the ruling class to say that we the
people without any institutional power
in this country including the military
anymore that we're the ones rigging the
elections that's completely insane you
got to admire them they're the ruling
class and the resistance it's amazing
it's quite amazing let me ask you this
you're a relatively new father yes simon
is how old now simon is nine and a half
months nine and a half to the day
since you mentioned that that this
virginia thing has so much to do with
the parents waking up has this changed
any of your perspective on any of this
i've been thinking about a lot like
we're working on having kids if i had a
four-year-old right now let's say
and they were saying five-year-olds are
about to get the injection i would be
looking at that calendar and looking at
the birthday and also looking at the
tickets out of town for sure naturally
and it wouldn't just be you and me and
all the other crazy right-wing
conspiracists it would be dr harvey rich
at yale a yale epidemiologist who just
came out and said
if your child is in a school with a
vaccine mandate you should homeschool
that's what you know assuming your kid
is healthy yeah you should homeschool
and so yeah i
i will say i intellectually
understood all of these things before
the little baby came yeah
but it's a very different thing now you
know it reminds me c.s lewis wrote this
book about
pain and suffering called the problem of
pain it's a very good book
and then he wrote another book called a
grief observed when his wife died and it
so it's kind of the same book
except they're totally different books
when when it is real to you when you
have a real stake in it yeah
you know it's it's the difference
between oh well we should really change
that policy to i'm gonna go rip
somebody's heart out of his chest if he
tries to screw with my kid yeah are you
shocked the way the democrats have done
this you don't have a right
to
have anything to do with your children's
education we're going to teach them all
this stuff we're going to inject them
it's like you got to kind of thank them
in a way they're going so overboard on
this that they are sort of doing our job
at this point right they are but they
they are only following their idea to
the logical conclusion right they're
only they're taking their id and frankly
it's the idea of public education to
begin with this doesn't just go back 20
30 years it doesn't just go back to
dewey it goes back to
horus really right i mean it goes back
to uh people even further further than
that
the idea that
because it goes back to the
revolutionary era the idea that public
education is supposed to form you not
just teach you the two plus two equals
four and how to read and write but also
civic virtues also
morality and ethics also to form a free
citizen you know and what what the left
has done since they've totally gotten
their their clause into education is
they are are creating the type of
citizens that they want not the citizens
who salute the flag and admire thomas
jefferson but the citizens who burn the
flag and topple the statues and make
tick-tock videos don't forget about
don't forget about the pink hair
tick-tock pretty creepy tick-tock videos
no i gotta let you go because you guys
are freaking out you apparently have to
talk in front of a couple hundred people
what should i say
talk about me how i've sort of
influenced you and and help moderate
your
crazy opinions and all that stuff
michael knowles thank you thank you if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell